let's bring in Bobby Wagner the Seahawks
linebacker joining us on the program
where are you today Bobby how you doing
I'm doing doing well is there a nap room
like if you guys wanted to take a nap
is there a nap place at the facility I
mean the facility is big enough pretty
sure she wants to take a nap you could
find somewhere to lay here but you know
we always work in here but you would
never take a nap okay all right you made
headlines with the block field goal here
now okay so there was a flag on the play
they picked it up so what what is your
logic there like when you guys decided
to do this what did you think and do you
have the authority to be able to do it
whenever you want to well you know kind
of what we saw we saw that they're lying
set a little low and you know we felt
like there was an opportunity to kind of
jump over them the the new rule was
basically like you couldn't run and jump
but if he started from the line of
scrimmage you could jump over him so you
know we've seen our opportunity and we
did it I know it's been a lot of talk
about you know that I used my hands or
just adding a third but for me
personally I didn't even know my hands
were on my teammate and so I watched the
film because I didn't I didn't push off
of them it's just kind of when you jump
like that your hands have to be
somewhere and it was kind of tight in
where I was at so you know if you watch
what I did in practice it was it was a
little bit similar but we didn't have
any pads on so it wasn't as tight but
you know they call what they call it's
over now so you know they can complain
about it or we can move on from it okay
I'll take it though should it be legal
how should it be legal to appeal the
entire plane I think if you got if you
have a chance to jump over you know I
think it should be legal you know I
think they kind of you know you feel
for player safety's but you know I kind
of felt like it was guys that wasn't
able to jump over the line starting to
jump all over LA and wasn't making it so
you know if you can't make it don't jump
what Pete Carroll's say when you came to
the sidelines that was you know we asked
you to play he was like man you did it
again you know we're trying to wait and
do it again so you know it was a fun
play man I think it's fun I think it
creates a little bit of excitement to
that particular play because a lot of
times you know people are looking and
waiting for the you know the sill go to
be missed or something like that so you
know I think it's fun to add a little
bit of element a little bit of
unexpectedness to that particular play
give the fans a little bit of something
to be excited for it said of Jim just
kind of walking away from the TV knowing
that it's gonna be a make or miss how
did it feel does it hurt when you Blanca
feel go no I hit I hit my hands hit my
hand so I was all good last time
when I when I blocked it in Arizona
it hit underneath my armpit and I left
the football yeah see that that's the
how about a tattoo maybe a tattoo of the
football leaving that mark on you if it
won the Superbowl
yeah if you won the Superbowl with
something like that then I could see
maybe you'd get the imprint of the
football like a tattoo right yeah maybe
you got to be a bigger situation you got
to be like one of them life changing
players he's Bobby Wagner he's the
Seahawks linebacker do you ever look
around did you ever look around and you
go where did everybody go of all the
guys that you played with I mean
honestly honestly I didn't I did it
until I didn't see KJ
because I was like as long as that you
know as long as I was with KJ I was good
and then when he kind of you know he had
his situation that he had I kind of
looked around like man you know this
this different look a little different
but
it's exciting to manage it's cool like
for me is like you kind of I kind of
felt like I was gonna play for I'm
playing for a long time and that's my my
goal is to play for for a while so I
knew at some point you know this is
gonna happen
you just didn't expect it to happen the
way that it happened and how sudden it
happened you thought it may be one
person at a time but and not you know
the whole defense at a time so I mean
it's an adjustment but you know I feel
like we we've had to live really well if
I gave you one Hall of Fame vote and you
can only vote for one guy you've played
with any position who would who would
get your Hall of Fame boat man that
stuff you want me to get one vote and I
got a vote for it this guy gets in your
vote gets him in so Sherman cam Russell
Marshall of the oldest who's the oldest
daughter yeah yeah I'm gonna go on my
side cuz he's the oldest but do you
really believe that he'd see a Hall of
Fame running back a hundred percent his
Earl I'm a Hall of Famer a hundred
percent Richard your possession damn
how'd you say Bobby Wagner I think some
plane to do he still got some planning
to do he not done yet
he still got some more here's the time
okay what happened with this team that
oh it's all of a sudden it clicked I
know that you guys are a running team
now but something had to happen it felt
like or a game or a moment that just
turned you guys into something you know
a very you know playoff team I don't
know it was a one moment or moments that
that clique I just think you know just
me kind of being around that 2012 team
and even that Super Bowl team you know
we were a very very young team and we
had to go through some things to to kind
of you know get to where we wanted to be
so I felt like the the young guys
to kind of see you know why dota guys
believe what we believe because you know
we you know like myself or us okay say
we've seen some crazy crazy games and so
you know we could have been down ten
with with 40 seconds left and we would
still feel like we can win because it's
it's happened before so we had to kind
of give that you know belief to the
young guys and they had to you know
truly believe it and I think you know as
the season went on and as you know their
confidence grow they believe that you
know we got this and you know I think
you know close games that we pull out
like Carolina and and games like that I
just think those are games that you know
help with everybody's confidence I know
what you'd be honest when you first
slipped on the uniforms on Monday night
when you first put that on and then you
look to yourself in the mirror what you
think as far as what our jerseys the way
they the green you look like a green
highlighter yeah honestly they're so you
got to come check amount of person this
is so dope they the best ratings in the
world they are a little bright on TV but
they work in my favor so you know you
know super stars shine bright so no okay
all right if you had that uniform on in
the dark in your house yeah you probably
see me I'm not winning with that you
know by the way Bobby thinks he's a
great basketball player he has compared
his game to a combination of LeBron
Jordan Kobe and Russell Westbrook is
that is that a fair assessment that's
pretty pretty it's pretty active you
think you could play my officer yeah
okay if Seattle gets an NBA team maybe
you should wanna you think you're gonna
try out I'm trying now I just need me
just give me ten days and I saw you have
you mean ten day okay best basketball
player you've faced you played against
no no anywhere actually you know what's
funny
after the Monday night game somebody did
she sent me a picture of me playing
while in ER in high school
really I was trying to box him out so
somebody send me a picture of that which
is actually funny that she just said
that
but Kauai I play quite Leonard in high
school and I remember playing demar
derozan in middle school and he dunked
in middle school and that's when I was
kind of like hey you know what maybe I'm
maybe the bachelor thing is not going as
well as I thought it was if I'm not
ducking like he ducking ok wait how did
you do against Kauai dad that seems
tacky I think we lost that game we lose
the new high school so we were still
trying to get you know bars that all
right hey congrats so far I think you're
probably gonna be up there for Defensive
Player of the Year at least you should
you should be in there in the top five
and been a great run and good luck in
the playoffs thank you I appreciate it
that's a Bobby Wagner for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]